welcome to your round 4 recap of the  2014 us Chess Championships here in st.  Louis well the leader Alex lindemann  continued to add to that lead defeating  his main rival ray Robson with a vicious  move rook to GA check if Ray had  captured pawn takes rook and after  getting a queen king takes the pawn  would steam home with check and with a  queen on the board the King would have  absolutely no chance over in the women's  championship we were joined by Alyssa  melaquin ax celebrating her First  dominant victory so now the important  thing is that I got my confidence back  took what lessons I could from my first  two rounds even the five about start  doesn't mean I have to end that way and  keep your eye on 13 year old phenom  ashritha estarán who's near the top of  the leaderboard in the women's  championships it was really great and  really excited be sure to join us here  in st. Louis at one p.m. Central at us  chess champs calm